je suis candidate d'abord et avant tout
pour servir la nation et mon territoire
c'est ma manière de servir mon pays et
les convictions que je porte pour lui
c'est aussi ma manière de pouvoir
défendre à l'échelle nationale les
problématiques que j'ai rencontré en
tant qu'élu de proximité celle que m'ont
rapporté les citoyens qui vivent au
quotidien
je souhaite jouer ce rôle de double
représentation aux côtés des élus et des
habitants de notre circonscription je
serai la députée du bon sens du terrain
de l'ecoute de l'action et de la
proximité qui sont bien plus que des
slogans mais des devoirs face aux défis
du 21e siècle nous devons définir ce que
nous voulons pour le rural de demain
car ce qui est en jeu c'est l'ambition
que nous avons pour le rural pour qu'il
soit symbole de modernité et d'une
nouvelle vision d'une nouvelle façon de
vivre face à la crise de nos
institutions et de la représentation
politique nous devons plus que jamais
être à l'éthique dans la logistique et
la bienveillance de tous nos habitants
pour améliorer leur quotidien il ne
suffit pas de voter selon une partition
politicienne des textes de loi ils de
stigmatiser des citoyens et des
territoires pour faire de la politique
il suffit d'être présente sur le terrain
de tout donner pour nos concitoyens est
d'être solide sur les convictions et les
combats à mener
[Musique]